hello everyone and welcome today we're
going to be showing you how to do
a key to program a key for a 2019 jeep
compass
using the zed full
programmer so what you want to do you
want to first
remove the cluster
here and get to this connector back here
then there's this adapter it's a
chrysler adapter this
is the b adapter we're gonna take that
out
connect it here and into our
cable right over here
right okay and now that we have our
connector
connected over here all right we're back
so you want to select
cheap and chrysler
model list
cheap compass beta
and that is 14 plus
tenure are we gonna
add a key
pin is 2900 actually let's
pull up the pen from the computer
extract pen
16 166 all right add a key
now you want to press the unblock
there you go you want to program another
key i'm going to say
no
all right and now let's test out the car
actually we can start it without the
cluster
there you go cars on
and that's how you program 2019 jeep
compass
using the zip fold thank you for
watching
if you like this video please give it a
like
and subscribe to the channel thank you